the wheat harvest season is almost over
Farmers say they had little choice but
to bolster production because of
lebanon's economic crisis and the rise
in global food prices
but the country is far from producing
enough amounts to meet local demand
in the past the percentage of farmers
who grew wheat was around 40 percent now
it's more than 70 percent if we get more
support we would be able to grow much
more
it is an expensive business
since Lebanon Imports almost everything
and the local currency lost more than 95
percent of its value
the nearly bankrupt government has
promised to support production by
providing seeds at a low price
we Face a lot of challenges to be able
to invest in our land we are poor we
need dollars to buy pesticides that's
why the government should support us
successive governments left
the tourist sector underfunded and
underdeveloped for decades and the
breakdown in government services means
there is a lack of water for irrigation
the financial meltdown has made the
situation of farmers worse some have
stopped their work high energy costs
affect their operations
the International Community has stepped
in the United Nations and ngos have been
helping develop a more sustainable local
food system the need is to increase
production and lower the cost
we have a big challenge all the way down
from the farmers the production the
production of wheat all the way down to
the people who are consuming it and
trying to buy the products as well
fundamentally in food insecurity has
risen during this time and we haven't
got enough wheat in the country to try
to keep the prices more stable so that's
some of the most vulnerable people can
buy the products
the war in Ukraine has affected Global
prices as well as disrupted the supply
chain Lebanon wants to end its
dependence on imports from that region
but there's a long way to go
there Al Jazeera a car Northern Lebanon